pub
[Musique]
bien sûr la pollution existe c'est
facile à voir
et ce n'est pas nouveau et pour qu'il y
ait pollution il faut bien qu'il y ait
peu le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 8 novembre 1971 le ministre de
l'environnement a déclaré à l'assemblée
nationale qui peut lui paie nous avons
voulu nous rendre compte si cette
volonté était devenu réalité dans les
faits si vraiment les pollueurs étaient
les payeurs
comme exemple nous avons choisi le
département de l'aisne est là pour
simplifier une seule pollution celle de
l'aude ouf
en savoie il ya du poisson beaucoup
madame monsieur bon bah suite à la
pollution position par ici à lorient
plus de 50 tonnes pour moi le poisson
mord un de poissons morts bic ont été
enlevés ah oui c'est certain mais je
suis ici d'une un exemple quelqu'un qui
va être pris à pêcher en une truite
quand la pêche est fermée il va avoir
une très grosse amende alors que celui
qui a détruit des tonnes l'époque unis
directement et aussi vite qu'un pêcheur
qui fait une infraction
et vous monsieur vous pensez que la
justice punisse suffisamment les
pollueurs ou pas non je suis un succès
ça n'existe pas un grand talent avec la
pollution qui a eu ici ce 4 ans que ça
dure la société d'accord il a touché
presque n est pas assez sévères justice
pour les plusieurs à des plus sévères
sont les plus à tout ça remet des
ossements pays qui pendant quatre ans
des lois ou les voiliers appliqué à
l'heure actuelle un procès qu'en matière
de pollution la loi n'est pas appliquée
non non écouter ce sont les villes les
principales coupables la preuve c'est
que tous les égouts de des nouveaux
quartiers là bas reviennent dans le
canal il n'y a pas une loi qui puisse
obliger la municipalité à faire quelque
chose mais non puisqu'elle est coupable
nous avons même vu une services
d'assainissement en train de nettoyer d
égout le long du canal rapport et tout
ce qui peut que ce qu'ils ramassaient
dans les égouts ils vivaient dans le
canal c'est pas vrai pour examiner de
plus près ces pollutions un guide
le président de la fédération des
pêcheurs de l'aisne andré delaby c'est
uniquement 50 uniquement 50 à la région
de saint quentin vous avez une deux
trois quatre cas trois affaires qui sont
passés par ici
aux environs de quoi près de
saint-quentin et qui fait ce dossier
c'est la fédération de pêche bien
entendu avec le concours des gardes de
la fédération qui font les prélèvements
et
s'ils sont étudiées par le laboratoire
de s'amender ça vous coûte cher écoutez
une pollution comme celle qui s'est
passé à saint quentin nous a coûté à peu
près millions d'anciens francs
alors c'est quoi alors alors ça oui où
ça c'est une pollution qu'elle lui en
1969 c'est la pollution de l'étang did
est un délit alors l'étang d'isle que
vous avez ici pour nous cette pollution
cette pollution était excessivement
importante puisque etc incendie de
cyanure se sont déversés dans les égouts
tu à la suite d'une rupture de durite
d'une usine
hélas le résultat j'étais prévenu qui
avait du poisson qui y était mort dans
l'étang on a trouvé 50 tonnes de
poissons de crever et 50 tonnes
cinquante tonnes de poissons après les
des recherches par nos gardes nous
sommes arrivés trois jours après à
trouver le responsable une irresponsable
celui ci nous l'avions contacté bien
entendu tout au début de la pollution et
il ne nous a laissés tels grèce ont fait
que trois jours après et ici les gens
que font-ils là ils peuvent se baigner
vous comme vous le voyez quand même il
ya des pêcheurs
il ya un établissement de bains il ya
des gens qui auraient pu se baigner à ce
moment là il reste je crois qu'il ya des
chiens qui ont un boulot qui n'aurait
rien qui crevait ç'aurait pu être
catastrophique que je ne sais pas si je
peux le dire mais que la ville de saint
quentin et et de l'eau avec des traces
de cyanure de l'eau de leur temps de
repos table oui
l'industriel était complètement
responsable maintenez vous bien il y en
ait deux ans après et passer en
correctionnelle
la condamnation la fédération obtenu le
franc symbolique qu'elle avait demandés
mais la condamnation du directeur a été
de 100 mille anciens francs et 100 mille
ans formé d'anciens francs
ici à notre exemple c'est une usine qui
se trouve sur la rive et rennes une
cartonnerie qui polluent depuis plus de
20 ans même comme vous le constaterez
l'eau est toujours excessivement noir et
cette eau à principe 20 juste à la
sortie de compiègne ça fait combien de
kilomètres là ça doit faire à peu près
80 km et l'eau est polluée c'est à dire
que l'eau est noir elle restera toujours
noir les poissons ne se reproduiront
plus puisque la faune et la flore va
disparaître vous avez fait un procès
nous allons déposer plainte est
actuellement dans les t'obliger si vous
voulez de faire une transaction amiable
puisque nous pouvions plus aller au
pénal
l'administration ayant abandonné à la
procédure contre d'industriels
à quoi vous jouez là alors là je prends
le loup je vais d'abord mesuré des
températures du rejet et j'en prends
dans les flacons dali pour faire des
allusions poussé nitrates phosphates
plus haut rue ans n'a pas une abc 2 elle
s'y serait une mesure du décès oh et
puis la mesure du début aussi ça marche
bon tout cela qui a l'air très compliqué
c'est pour voir si l'eau est pure ou pas
pu faire ça mais a priori elle n'a pas
l'air de très pur c'est-à-dire qu'on
peut remarquer qu'il ya quand même des
paquets de moussy on a évalué à péage de
droit dessus ce qui est déjà quand même
fortement à site pour un rejet
d'ailleurs vous pouvez regarder
du point de vue coloration la différence
des deux plages
dans les mystères récepteur c'est à dire
qu'ici c'est déjà le fleuve c'est la
nature qui s'était enfui sow qui rejoint
la rive ersonne et si vous voyez qu'il
ya une grossière décantation rien ne
retient pas un traitement biologique ou
chimique destiné à rendre les eaux usées
compatible avec une milieu récepteur et
ça sort directement de lusine
pratiquement il ya brève à peu près 20
ans si vous voulez que en bataille avec
avec lui signé pour les obliger soulevé
à décanter le roseau alors jusqu'à
maintenant mais ya rien eu de fait comme
vous le voyez lusine a doublé sa
production
c'est ce qui s'est passé est bien
entendu maintenant c'est cocasse puisque
cette pollution que nous avons ici vous
voyez le début se fait sentir jusque
dans le département de la somme c'est à
dire sur ce pauvre à plus de 30 km mais
on me trouve un sage heures ça fait à
peu près de 30 km suivi de pollution
alors actuellement je suis avait porté
plainte convivialité une plainte qui a
été déposée en mai 1971 jusqu'à
maintenant nous attendons toujours le
résultat malgré deux différentes
démarches n'est jamais une solution
ah bon vous n'avez aucune nouvelle n'a
aucune nouvelle et alors que nous avons
eues à la suite d'une pollution du site
de la cda
une pollution catastrophique puisque
située à plusieurs tonnes de poissons
nous n'avons perdu 17 houston en 1971 et
ça fait donc deux ans que vous dites
cette eau est polluée et l'est toujours
pollués donc mon rapport et n'ont pas
l'air d'avoir une utilité très grave
aucun effet aucun effet aucun effet
andré de la bi vous l'êtes encore vous
montrez 37 cas de pollution nous sommes
allés évoqué l'ensemble du problème avec
d'autres responsables des pêcheurs du
département ait agi seul est créé on y
croit on fait des discours nous voulons
que la loi soit appliquée c'est ce que
nous demandons au travail et bien se
vendre
nous sommes allés voir le préfet
puisqu'il est responsable du respect de
la loi
[Musique]
vous pensez que c'est beaucoup mieux la
concertation que une action judiciaire
je pense que les deux doivent suivre un
cours parallèles lorsque les
circonstances l'exigent
mais jusqu'à présent sur les grosses
affaires dont je vous parle il n'y a pas
lieu d'envisager de poursuites
judiciaires
les industriels appliquant très
loyalement au prix d'un gros effort
malgré l'aide qui leur est donné les
suggestions que je leur impose
mais nous avons vu cette usine de vous
parler elle a installé des bassins de
décantation etc
mais l'eau continue à sortir pour lui
c'était un spectacle c'est les priant ne
vous fiez pas à la couleur de l'eau je
vous répète qu' on a déterminé et ça a
été fait par notamment l' agence
financière de passage qui a des
techniciens des mines dans ce qu'on
appelle l'objectif de qualité de l'eau
est progressivement par les épurations
d'abord physique puis biologique on
arrivera à le rejeter une quantité
d'éléments polluants tels que l'objectif
de la qualité de l'eau sera respectée et
pourtant vous voyez du moose un saut
considérable qu'il soit là mais
précisément ces mots sans ramasser et va
évacuer et ne sont pas rejetés dans la
rivière comme c'était précédemment dit
qu'à des produits polluants eux mêmes
les gens de la région nous ont dit
également qu'il ya des pressions de ses
influences qui vous empêche de faire
appliquer la loi qui a de grosses usines
de gros groupes financiers
croyez bien que l'on lit tout jeune sera
pas préfet si je ne prenais pas mes
responsabilités en toute indépendance et
sans jamais céder à aucune pression je
ne veux pas devenir n'a pas mais ce ne
sont pas des pressions politiques
[Musique]
on
de l'administration passons à la justice
dans ce décor accueillant le président
de l'union fédérale des magistrats andré
bègue nous dit son opinion problème de
répression sont assez complexes en
matière d'environnement parce qu'il ya
toujours des répercussions sociales et
économiques
je prends un exemple en matière
d'urbanisme il est certain que des
promoteurs et des architectes peuvent
commettre les infractions graves faire
bâtir ou bâtir un édifice qui ne
correspond pas aux normes et qui peut
même être dangereux pour l'entourage et
bien supposer que vous faites arrêter la
construction ou que même vous fait
supprimer abattre l'édifice vous allez
peut-être empêcher des gens de se
reloger
prenez un autre exemple dans la
pollution industrielle
vous avez des petites entreprises
artisanales notamment en province qui
sont équipés de d'équipement anciens qui
sont des équipes qui ont des équipements
pollueurs et bien dans ces petites
entreprises si vous êtes tout de suite
d'une rigueur absolue si vous fait
fermer l'établissement
si vous condamnez le
le petit industriel ou l'artisan à des
peines grave mais vous allez provoquer
la fermeture d'établissements et même
s'il s'agit d'une fermeture momentanée
vous allez mettre en chômage
les ouvriers peut-être quinze vingt
ouvriers de cette entreprise et ça peut
être très grave pour l'économie de cette
localité
je vais vous montrer une loi qui n'est
pas récente et qui pourtant si en
matière de pollution
elle était appliquée pourrait donner des
résultats excellents
il s'agit de l'article 434 1 du code
rural et je me permettrai de vous lire
brièvement ce texte
quiconque aura jeté déversé dans les
cours d'eau directement ou indirectement
des substances quelconques dont l'action
ou les réactions ont détruit le poisson
ou nui à sa nutrition sera puni d'une
amende de 500 francs à 5000 francs et
d'un emprisonnement de dix jours un an
ou de l'une de ces deux peines seulement
on a un texte qui nous le verrons tolère
n'est certainement pas à piquer à
l'heure actuelle mais qui est
extrêmement intéressant puisqu'il
présente un moyen de dissuasion
considérable à l'égard des pollueurs
à condition bien sûr qu'il y ait du
poisson dans la rivière qui sera polluée
c'est la limite de ce texte et elle est
évidemment très importante
alors qu'au contraire dans des pays
comme l'allemagne très récemment un
industriel allemand un directeur d'usiné
a été mis en prison pour 18 mois de
prison ferme parce qu'il avait jetée du
cyanure des tonnes de cyanure dans une
rivière sava un arrêt de la cour de
cassation du 14 février 1973 donc tout
récent qui déclare que ce n'est pas le
patron qui doit être puni en matière de
pollution
c'est le préposé et cela est fâcheux car
cela entraîne une irresponsabilité
naturellement des présidents des
sociétés qui savent que toute façon ils
ne seront pas personnellement inquiéter
leur société ira peut-être 2000 francs
d'amendé
et quand il s'agit de très grandes
sociétés
seize pas grand chose et eux mêmes ne
seront pas en fait inquiète
[Musique]
et maintenant que pense de tout cela
monsieur robert poujade ministre de la
protection de la nature et de
l'environnement celle mise dans le film
que nous venons de voir
il est probable que cette réflexion d'un
pêcheur a dû vous impressionné quand il
dit lorsque la pêche est fermée et que
l'on pêche l'amande pour avoir pris une
truite est bien plus importante que la
mangue que paierait un pollueur
réflexion bien française n'est ce pas
c'est à dire que ce sont toujours les
petits qui trinquent et les gros n'ont
rien ou c'est moi qui suis condamné mais
pas le voisin ce pas parce que on ne
croira la justice que quand on en subit
soi même les effets enfin vous ne voulez
pas vous donner l'image d'un père
fouettard de l'environnement je vous
dirais que je ne suis pas pour l'
indulgence excessive et par exemple je
puis vous dire que j'ai demandé moi-même
que les abandons d'objets en dehors des
décharges soient sévèrement punis
est ce que les français savent bien il
faut peut-être leur dire qu'aujourd'hui
il en coûte de 80 à 160 francs
si l'on abandonne un objet en dehors
d'une décharge que si ça se fait avec
une voiture ça coûte 1000 francs plus
éventuellement la confiscation de la
voiture
cela dit je ne suis pas non plus un père
fouettard
je n'exige pas la répression à tout prix
et n'importe comment
je demande la justice et je souhaite
qu'avant la justice au sens pénal du
terme ne s'exerce
il y est bien sûr le maximum
d'informations et le maximum de
concertation je ne veux pas réduire de
nombreux ouvriers
au chômage par exemple par excès de
rigueur dans certains cas où
manifestement il ya des problèmes
sociaux
tout cela je dois le prendre en compte
cela fait aussi probablement partie de
la justice de ce qu'on appelle la
justice sociale si les français vraiment
ont de plus en plus l'exigence de cette
morale de l'environnement dont parlait
naguère le président de la république
bien croyez-moi les magistrats qui sont
gens intègres attentif à l'esprit du
temps les suivront et même les
précéderont de plus en plus
[Musique]